- Good morning. Welcome to re:Invent.
Oh yeah, definitely put on the,
actually you don't have
to, whatever you want.
If you do put on the headphones
and I'm speaking too loud or too softly,
you have a volume button
on the right side, I think.
So,
let's say we're building a game.
All of us are starting
a new gaming startup
and we are going to create a
massive online multiplayer game
that if we're successful,
is going to support hundreds
of thousands of users.
So we are going to need massive scale,
probably millions of requests per second.
And we are going to have to
maintain very low latency
for our users to have a
consistently responsive game.
Otherwise, they probably
won't play our game.
We are going to use ElastiCache
Serverless for Valkey
because it provides
predictably low latency
and supports the massive
scale that we need.
Now, my name is Elad. This is Yaron.
We both work for ElastiCache.
And ElastiCache Serverless does take away
many concerns that you have
as a developer or DevOps.
For instance, you don't
have to worry about
security patching, you
don't have to worry about
version upgrades.
But most importantly, you
don't have to worry about
sizing your cluster and
you don't have to scale it
when your application load increases.
This session is going to
talk about optimizations
that are relevant
for very, very high
performance applications.
And optimizations are going to be relevant
both for ElastiCache Serverless,
also for self design clusters,
or even if you're
self-managing your own fleet
of Open Source Redis or Valkey.
Valkey, in case you're
not familiar with Valkey,
it's an open source in-memory database.
It was fork out of Redis when
they change their license.
And Valkey has been adopted
by the Linux Foundation
and it's maintained by
a very big community,
very active community,
including some industry leaders
and a few cloud providers including AWS.
Let's go back to our game.
So let's start with the
POC of our game, right?
We are just in our labs now.
We are taking a few, a couple of clients,
connected them to a Node.js server, right?
Node.js, that's easy.
That's, that's fun.
So we'll probably just store all the state
of our game in memory, right?
That would include things
like where our users are,
where the monsters are,
maybe their health, things like that.
And we are going to use some disk
if you wanna store some
more persistent resources.
For instance, our game
maps, our castle map,
things like that, that
don't change that often.
And so
our users on the POC,
our users are probably
going to have terrific,
just terrific latency, right?
Within the lab, what would you expect
in the lab for latency?
Any ideas?
Okay, so usually when latency,
when networking is very,
is not a concern,
you would see latencies
of around 100 microseconds round trips.
Most of these latency would
come from the operating system,
the network stack, the kernel,
communicating with user node, right?
So it's not really network latency here,
it's mostly just the operating system.
And when we go and access memory
for our state management, right?
Reading state, changing state,
we're probably going to have access times
of a few tens of micro, of nanoseconds.
Sorry, nanoseconds.
So that means that we can actually
go to the, go to memory many, many times
before it actually impacts
significant latency, right?
We could do it hundreds of
time on a single user request,
maybe even thousands of times
without it impacting latency.
This is very different when we talk about
disk latencies, right?
Even if you have the best, the best SSD,
it's going to be a little less
than one millisecond probably,
but it's going to vary, right?
Why is it going to vary?
Because when you read an object from disk,
you are not just doing a single access.
Sometimes you're doing multiple accesses
because disk store objects
on different blocks, right?
So disk latency is usually very variable,
which we probably want in our application.
Yes, no?
No, probably no, right?
We don't want this variability.
And so I mean for our, for our game POC,
we can probably just load all the maps
when we start keeping 'em in memory
and then you just use them there, right?
But when we take this to production,
it's going to be a little bit different.
So now our users are on the internet,
we're using multiple
instances of our application
because we want scale and we
also want high availability.
We'll probably use a bunch
of availability zones to get that.
And our resources, instead of disk,
are going to be naturally
placed in some database.
So, but when we read the database,
latency is going to be,
again, very variable.
Somewhere, probably
typically one millisecond
to a hundred milliseconds.
And that's because traditional databases,
whether it's a relational database
or a document database,
I mean those usually use a combination
of both memory and disk
to deliver queries.
And it's very hard to control
where your queries are serviced from.
It's hard to say, hey,
everything must come from memory.
And I guess that's where
Valkey becomes very, very handy
because Valkey uses exclusively memory
to serve your queries.
It provides you with predictable latency.
And I think that's what
we want for our game,
by the way, for any application,
doesn't have to be a game, right?
We chose the game because games are fun.
But any application that needs
millions and millions
of requests per second
on strict latency requirements,
Valkey is very useful.
Again, because of the low variability.
I mean, Valkey uses memory,
so most of the latency you'll see,
it's not even coming from Valkey usually.
The most dominant factor
with Valkey latency
is probably going to
be the network, right?
And so if you are on the same AZ
as your Valkey, know
that you're accessing,
you'll probably have latencies
far below one millisecond,
sub-millisecond latency.
Now, it may be that your application
needs to go from another AZ and access
a Valkey node on a different AZ,
and then latency increases,
increases slightly.
And I'll dive deeper into
these latencies in a minute.
But what if, right?
What if, if we could manage application
such that we are reading
from a replica node
that's on the same AZ?
That way we can maintain
at least for our reads,
we can maintain low latency
for all of our application instances,
lowering our p50 and our average
latencies for application.
Sorry.
Let's dive deeper into latencies.
So we're going to talk about,
we're talking about milliseconds,
we're going to talk about microseconds
and we're talking about nanoseconds.
That's the world we live in.
Let's start off with your users.
When you have users
coming over the internet,
connecting to your application,
usually or typically you'll
see latencies somewhere
between 20 milliseconds
up to 100 milliseconds,
maybe even 150.
It really depends on where
your users are, right?
They could be very
close to the data center
with an excellent internet connection,
and they could be very far away.
They could be on another continent.
So that's the variability we'll see.
When we continue into the data center,
if you are communicating
between two servers in
the same data center,
latencies are going to be very, very low.
It's very similar to the
lab we discussed before.
So network latency is going
to be nanoseconds usually,
and it's going to be around 75,
100 microsecond round trips.
Again, usually because of
operating systems, right?
You can optimize that
using tools like DPDK maybe
that optimize this kernel
to user node latency.
But usually that's what you'll see.
And these are very low latencies anyway.
Now, when we go from one data center
to another on the same AZ,
we can expect latencies
of up to one millisecond.
In case you're not familiar with this,
AZs usually have one or more data centers.
They're not just a single data center.
And these data centers can
be miles and miles apart.
So latency is slightly higher.
And when you go, when you go over
the AZ to another AZ,
those data centers are
even more far apart, right?
And then latency can in some regions,
oh sorry, can be,
can be milliseconds.
Now the most dominant factor
here is distance, right?
We have to carry this
signal over fiber optics
from point A to point B and back, right?
So we are bound by the speed of light.
That's the, that's the thing.
So if they're closed, it's
going to be good latency.
If they're farther apart,
it's going to be higher.
Let me share some real life examples.
I hope you can read this.
I'll try and read this aloud.
What we're looking at are actual latencies
from US-EAST-1 region.
I took this a few days ago
when I prepared the slides.
And these are cross-AZ latencies,
latencies from AZa to Azb, AZ1 to AZ2,
AZ2 to, AZ1 to AZ3,
just a few measurements.
And you can see if you're
unable to read this,
most of these latencies are far below
700 microseconds, right?
These are the cross-AZ ones.
So we said they could be
millisecond, in this case,
in this particular region,
an AZ is the far lower.
Let's zoom in.
Now what happens inside each AZ.
Latencies that are coming,
that are comparing inside each AZ,
so there's a latency from
two points inside AZ1
and other latency from two
points to machines in Azb.
These latencies are much lower
as you can probably spot, right?
And most of them are around
or below 100 microseconds.
So excellent latency in this case.
There's some variance here.
It depends on which region you use
and which AZs, where they are,
where those placed, the
distance between them.
What you could do,
these charts are not
something internal to AWS.
You can all view them.
I see nodding heads, you know this.
So you can check out something
called the network manager,
it's available on your AWS
console, of course the APIs.
And you can actually take
a look at all the latencies
between different regions,
different AZs in those regions.
And then you can look at your application
and consider the factors that,
that around latency here.
What latency can we expect between AZs?
What latency can we
expect between regions?
Any use case that you have.
Moving on.
So,
you folks have tasked me
with creating our first
microservice for the game.
And I didn't do an amazing job, spoilers.
And I created this microservice
for getting user profiles.
Now, this is not a good practice.
See if you can spot my mistake here.
Okay, I see some smiley faces,
don't laugh at me, right?
So let's cover what
we're doing here, right?
This is a very simplified HTTP server.
Whenever there's a new request,
the first thing that it does,
it goes and creates a new Valkey client,
calls connect, and then
does a get for the profile
that we actually need.
Now the problem here,
you can probably see it
is whenever we have a request,
we are doing all these
things just to get a single,
a single key, right?
We get a new connection.
That means DNS query.
It means TCP handshake,
TLS initialization, it
means cluster discovery,
doing cluster slots,
understanding where everything is placed
on the cluster, right?
And then finally what we actually wanted,
which was getting the key,
doing the GET command.
So I'm sure most of you
have already know this,
but the good practice is to
use persistent connections.
And that means just taking
this connection initialization
part, taking it outside,
oh, sorry about that.
Now I'm sure you know this,
but persistent connections
are extremely important
and you can actually do them
even if your compute is lambda.
Some people don't realize it,
but lambdas, I mean they don't actually
get torn down after each call, right?
They persist.
If you have more quality, they remain hot.
So persistent are definitely useful
both for EC2, ECS, Kubernetes
or on the use cases.
But
another important point about connections
is to understand what happens
when we do this good practice, right?
So pipelining is another important factor
that can influence performance,
especially when you are,
when you have a high
performance application.
Let me explain.
Pipelining, by the way,
it means sending out multiple requests
on the same TCP connection
without waiting for responses.
And this is exactly what's going
to happen in our web server
because take a look,
what happens when a user,
user one sends a request
and the server reads it?
It tell the request is going to shoot out
a GET command to our Valkey, right?
Now, this is asynchronous, right?
We are doing in a wait here,
that means that execution waits,
but the server is not blocked, right?
It can continue servicing
more requests in the meantime.
So another request is read
from user2 and what happens?
It gets sent well and user3,
and it gets sent as well.
So now we have a pipeline,
even though I haven't
written the word pipeline
anywhere on this code, right?
It's kind of an implicit pipeline.
And that's what happened.
And don't try to get me
wrong, pipelines are great.
Pipelining is an excellent
way to increase latency
with Valkey or Open Source Redis
because it's kind of even
you send things in batches.
The server has to do less work
in order to service them, right?
Less IO, maybe they can read
all the requests in a single IO operation.
I think the problem is
when these pipelines,
when you have very high performance
and our game is going to
have millions of requests
and the concurrencies
going to be very high
for each of these application web server.
And then what happens if
this is not three requests
at the same time but 1,000?
And that's where things
get a little bit dicey.
Let's zoom into the TCP connection.
So we had request number
one, user number one,
request for user number two,
request for user number three.
Now the rest protocol for both Valkey
and Open Source Redis is ordered.
That means that responses
must arrive in the same order
as the request that we send.
So very susceptible to
head of line blocking.
What happens if user one
requested a very, very large profile?
We have to read all the
response for user one
before we read the response
for user two and three.
And so
that response for user one is literally
holding the head of the line for us.
And again, with small numbers
it's not significant, with
large numbers more so.
And there's another problem.
What happens if you run into packet loss?
Should we even, I mean we're using TCP,
I mean, should we even
worry about packet loss?
No, yes?
So I mean, TCP does guarantee delivery.
The only problem is that
retransmissions in TCP
take at least 200
microseconds to happen, right?
That's hardcoded on the Linux kernel.
It's not something you
can do without rebuilding
it yourself or something.
So if we are having this large request
or just a request, it's not large.
And there's 1,000,
1,000 requests waiting behind it
and there's a packet loss.
All these requests, all
these users are going
to have a major impact.
Now, packet loss is fact of life
when you have a distributed system, right?
We cannot avoid it,
but we definitely want to reduce
the impact when it happens.
And the way to do that is to
use more connections, right?
We can use more connections
from the same application,
thus limiting the concurrency
on each of these connections.
And that helps us
minimize the blast radius,
whenever there's a large
response or something like that.
I mean, we can even
think about things like,
hey, if I know this type of
request is going to be slower,
I can maybe place it on
a dedicated connection.
That's another idea we can consider.
By the way, another very easy way
to reduce concurrency on each connection
is just to scale out
your application, right?
The more application instances we have,
the less work each of them
needs to do concurrently.
Of course that comes with a cost.
Let's talk about connection pooling.
So connection pooling means
using multiple connections
from the same application instance.
Some Valkey and Redis clients
have connection pools built in,
but many of these clients,
especially the are
synchronous ones, don't.
They actually use a single connection
and kind of multiplex
request in that connection.
And so what we could do
if we actually need
high concurrency, right?
If you're talking about millions
of requests for application
and we have high concurrency
over a single connection,
we can actually build them ourselves.
And for our game we can
build something like this.
Notice what I'm doing here,
instead of creating one
persistent connection,
I've just looped and
created a bunch of them.
And whenever I want to use the connection,
I need to pick one, right?
I can choose.
So in my case, if you'll notice here,
I've done a module over the user id
just to kind of load balance
between these connections.
But you can do randomization as well.
You can do round-robin,
you can module over something else
that makes sense for your application.
Okay, so everything is fine.
Our game runs perfectly.
Our cluster is very healthy,
it has a lot of total resources, right?
We have enough total memory,
enough total CPU,
enough total network bandwidth,
everything is peachy
and then suddenly it's not, right?
Even though we have enough resources,
we have an alarm, our latency is spiking,
our throughput is reducing
and going to scramble to
figure out what happened.
And a lot of cases,
what happens is that we
can run into hotspots.
Hotspots mean that a lot
of your traffic are hitting
one particular node in the cluster, right?
And that's usually
because you have hot keys.
So you have a key that's very popular
and you need to read it a lot of times.
But with Valkey and Redis,
doesn't matter if it's
serverless or not serverless,
each shard actually owns, sorry,
each key is owned by a single shard.
And so, I mean, if this weren't,
if we're diving into the,
in the metrics to understand
what the problem is.
Let's say we all went through the metrics,
we reached the network bandwidth case,
we see all of the shards,
that's all of the shards
do kind of moderate bandwidth network,
network bandwidth and one of
them is significantly higher.
And that's probably a good
indication of a hotspot.
Now what happens here?
When we, all of us dove into
and debugged our situation,
we found that we have particular
castle map in the game.
That's 100 kilobytes in size,
so not very huge, right?
And it's very popular. Users love it.
That's a good thing and we
have to read it a lot of times.
But the problem is that
say we didn't choose
ElastiCache Serverless for
this particular example,
we chose an, for our nodes,
which has 937 megabytes per
second bandwidth, right?
If you calculate and you
divide it by 100 kilobytes,
you can only do around
1,000 requests per second
for this object.
I mean, that's extremely
low for Valkey, right?
Just 1,000 requests per second.
And, and so the most obvious thing
that we can do in these cases
is probably to just scale
up our nodes, right?
We take the nodes, we replace them
with larger instance types,
let's say twice as large.
So we get twice the bandwidth
and we can do instead of 1,000,
we can do 2,000.
But of course this comes with a cost.
And also by the way, with serverless
you don't have to worry
about this particular,
about scale up because
serverless automatically scales
your instances up in place.
And Yaron is going to dive
deeper into that in a minute.
But I mean even with serverless,
what if you don't want x2?
What if you want x4?
What if you want,
actually what if you
want x10 or x50 or x100?
We are not gonna find an instance types
with that much network, right?
Just doesn't exist.
So what can we do?
One ice mitigation that we can try
is we can duplicate our object, right?
We can take our castle map,
all of our castle maps
and we can create copies of them.
Now because each copy is a different key.
It get placed in a different shard.
And now whenever we read a
castle map from application,
we can choose which copy to get
and now we we're spreading the load,
the kind of load balancing,
the load of reading these objects
between different shards.
Now think about it, with
serverless it automatically scales.
Scales, sorry.
And it can reach hundreds of nodes.
That means that if you do
100 copies of your object,
if you need, if you need 100 copies,
you'll get 100 times your throughput.
Another thing that we of course can do,
we can read from replicas, right?
If we can read from replicas,
we have more nodes kind
participating in our load balancing.
Let me show you a very naive example
of code for this.
We have our CastleCache
and when we read, what we need to do
is to choose one of our copies, right?
So we're choosing a copy
and here to modular over
the application worker id.
It helps me maybe with data consistency,
but you can randomize,
you can do round-robin,
you can do whatever business logic
makes sense for your applications.
Do you folks already see the caveat here?
What happens when we want
to update the castle map?
We have to go and update
all the copies, right?
So if there's 10 copies or 100 copies,
we have to do 100 writes.
So,
and this really works great
for situations when
you have a lot of reads
but not as many writes.
That's a very common use case, right?
This is very, this is super helpful
or it can be.
But if you do have to do a lot of reads
and writes at the same
kind of frequencies,
this won't work for you.
So we have another
mitigation that we can try.
It's a little bit more
work on application,
but we can actually split,
break apart our object into smaller ones.
So for our game, we can take each castle
and maybe break it down
into rooms or areas.
And now when we want to read them,
we can actually pipeline multiple reads,
get all the parts for our castle
and then assemble them
on the application side.
And now see how the load is again
spread over more shards,
kind of mitigating the hotspot.
And if we can do further
optimizations for application,
we can maybe, maybe we can down the line
write logic that we don't
need to get all the rooms
for a particular user,
we can just get a subset
of things like that.
And of course you can use
your imagination outside
of this game example to
see how you can break apart
your object and your application.
Right, now let me turn over to Yaron
who is going to tell you
how we designed ElastiCache Serverless,
how we're doing all
this automatic scaling?
Thank you.
- Thank you, Elad.
So a moment before I dive
deep into the serverless
and the way that we
build all the technology
behind the scenes.
Elad mentioned multiple
challenges that we need to,
to take care when we build an application,
specifically for build
them for high scale.
So I want to tell you with
ElastiCache Serverless,
you don't need to worry
about capacity planning
or rightsizing your cluster.
You can still achieve
millions request per second
with the sub-milliseconds response time,
just using by ElastiCache Serverless.
Now when you create an endpoint
to ElastiCache Serverless,
automatically we are distributing
all the infrastructure
of the serverless across
multiple availability zone.
We do that first for high
resiliency, high availability,
but we also do that to achieve
a very good performance
and to reduce the latency.
I will show you in a
moment how it's happening.
So once you create your endpoint
to ElastiCache Serverless,
you connect from your
VPC using VPC endpoint
to the ElastiCache Serverless VPC.
At the beginning you are
going to reach the NLB,
and the NLB responsible
to balance the traffic
across the serverless proxy.
Now I'm going to talk about the
proxy in the next few slides
and to explain why we build the proxy,
but overall the main job of the proxy
is to route your request
to the correct cache node.
Now we also know to locate your
local proxy that sit on
the same availability zone
so you can reach the minimum latency
while you connect to
ElastiCache Serverless.
So as I mentioned, the proxy responsible
to route the request to
the correct cache node
and you know to do it
very, very effectively.
The reason that you know
to do it effectively
is because we are using a
multiplex in technology,
multiplex in protocol.
We actually use a TCP, single TCP channel
to connect the cache node
while we are moving on
that TCP channel multiple
different connections of clients.
And in that way we are reducing
the number of connection
and we also reducing the number
of system call upon every
network transaction.
Now I want to move back
to the cache node itself.
We are running on a
multi-tenant environment,
we're running on a physical host
that we are constantly
monitoring all the time.
We have service that we
call it heat management
and the job of the heat
management is to monitoring
the cache node, all the
physical host across our fleet.
Now because we are running on
a multi-tenant environment,
we are sharing resources like
CPU, memory and networking.
And the cache nodes running inside the VM
within the physical host.
And as you can see, each cache
node has a different size.
And the reason for that is
because each cache node has a
different workload to digest.
Now our job as a
serverless is to make sure
that you have the enough extra capacity
to run your workload.
So I mentioned before that
we have the heat management
process that run and consolidate
all the physical host
status across our fleet.
And because we are constantly monitoring
and making sure that we don't,
you do have enough resource
to run your workloads,
we are in some situation
we can find a physical loss
that reach to some threshold.
For example, in here what you see,
we reach to some threshold
of memory and network
and we need to start to think how to move,
to evict some of the cache
node from this physical host
to a more available physical host.
So we are running the, we
are using the algorithm
of the power of the two random choices.
We actually picking two,
the two most hottest cache node
and we are choose to
move only the second one.
The reason that we are choosing
to move only the second one
is because we don't want to
interrupt the most busy one
that probably going under heavy load
and start to with maybe
scaling operations.
So we want to let them succeed
but we still want to move the one
that will release enough resources
once we move them to a
more available cache node.
Now Elad before that explain
you why it's so important
to have a persistent connection.
There is a cost when you
create a new connection
and with the proxy, we promise
you while all the changes
happening behind the scene
to store your connection
and to have it persistent to
the ElastiCache Serverless.
Of course the proxy will also responsible
to move the connection to the
new created the cache node,
the one that we moved to
a different physical host.
And in that way we are keeping
all the fleets very balanced
with all the enough
resources that is required.
Now there are some situation
that you cannot wait
for the heat management
to free enough resources
for your workload and you need
something more drastically.
You need to handle a burst of a workload
that kicks in because of event
or something that now is
happening in your business.
And for that we build
a very nice technology
in the ElastiCache
Serverless to support that.
We are actually using
a platform technology
that does not have a fixed
memory or CPU footprint
and can be rescaled up
and down very instantly.
We are using the technology that,
this technology based on a
multi-talented environment
so we can keep the cost very minimal.
So our, this technology allow us
actually to scale up very quickly
and to use the more cause
and memory that we have
on the physical host.
And actually we can support
eight time more throughput
on demand while once there are kicks in
into the serverless technology,
serverless endpoint.
Now because we start with scale up,
now we have time to start the
scale horizontally, scale out.
And the way we do that
there are three main stages.
We have the detection which
is happening very quickly.
We also have the ability to project
the income in the upcoming workloads
because we are constantly
monitoring your workloads.
And we know to predict
what would be the workload
in the next coming minutes.
So we can prescale your
cluster behind the scene
and be ready for the
workloads that can come.
Now the second stage is the provisioning.
To provision a new node is very costly,
but we are using a warm pool.
Warm pool is list of cache
node predefined, preinstalled
that waiting to be attached
very quickly to the cluster.
Now once we use the warm pool,
we are attaching them to the cluster
and the next, the last
phase that now is required
is to move the data
from the original shards
to the new shards that we just attached.
So for that we are doing,
we are monitoring the data within the slot
and we are capable to determine
which of the slots are considered as hot
and which of them are cold.
And based on that we can decide which slot
we want to move to which target.
We can do that in
parallel within the slot.
So we can move them very quickly
and we can do it in parallel
between the different targets.
So we can actually assign
multiple targets to our cluster
and to transfer the data in parallel.
So the scale out happens so quickly
so we can double the cluster
throughput every two minutes.
Now I promised that I
will speak about proxy
and the reason why we build it.
First we decided to build,
to have a single logical entry point
to the serverless cluster
and for that we build the proxy.
The proxy main job is to route the request
from the client application
to the cache node.
So it's actually encapsulate
all the underlying cluster
topology, everything
that related to failover,
disconnection, scaling,
everything that happened behind the scene.
So your application can consist
with a single connection
to the proxy while the proxy
will maintain thousands
of connection behind the
scene to the cluster.
And you don't need to be careful about
because you can scale your throughput
very instantly using this proxy technology
and all the scaling that I mentioned.
So you can jump from 0 to 5 million
request per second in only 12 minutes.
Now if your application
is latency sensitive
and you don't have a strong
consistency requirement,
you can use the read
form that we also have it
on ElastiCache Serverless.
Every time that you create
without. (faintly speaking)
We create one primary
and two replica as a
beginning of the shard.
Now if you want to connect to the replica,
the only thing that you need to do
is to flag the connection that you want
to read the data from the replica
and the proxy will do it for you.
Another thing that the proxy
will always make sure to do
is to read always from the
local availability zone.
So regardless if it's primary or replica,
the proxy will make sure to read the data
from the local AZ so you
can achieve the microseconds
response time.
Now let's take a look
how to build the code
so we can see how simple is it
to work with ElastiCache Serverless.
So here in my code I'm just connecting
to my ElastiCache Serverless.
I'm using TLS enabled because
always when we running
on serverless we support
only TLS connection.
And here I'm flagging on
that specific connection.
I'm telling to the proxy,
I want this connection
also to read the data
from the replication so I can
scale the read throughput.
And I can also achieve the
sub-milliseconds response time.
Here I have three very
simple block of codes.
The first one just populate
a few keys to my cache nodes,
to my cache serverless.
The second one is a fall loop
that I'm fetching the data
for my cache node.
And the third one is pretty
the same just with pipeline.
I'm doing a batch of multiple keys
that are running altogether.
Now as simple as that is that we are going
through the proxy.
Now the proxy will make sure
that to spread the request
to the correct shard behind the scene.
It will also promise me
that if there is any disconnection scaling
that happened in parallel, fail over,
nothing will disrupt my connection.
Everything is happening
because the proxy will take care of that.
And the most important is
that the proxy will promise me
to read the data from my
local availability zone.
As you can see the beautiful thing here
is that my code stay clean.
I don't need to worry about that,
I don't need to put any
special code to do that.
Everything is happening and
doing and managed by the proxy.
Now, I want to go back to Valkey.
Elad talked about Valkey, all the example,
all the technology that we build here
is based on the Valkey.
And I want to show you
how we leverage the Valkey technology
even to improve the serverless scaling
that we offer today for our customers.
So I want to go back in time
and to see how Valkey started.
Valkey designed as a
single threaded process
and the main reason for
that it was simplicity.
Because there is no race condition,
no synchronization is needed
and you can still scale out
and to use the share nothing architecture
and to improve the cache coherency.
With this technology,
with this technology we can achieve
around 190K request per second
and 50% of the time we are going
to be busy on the IO, on read and write.
Now to simulate that we
have the main thread.
Every time that another
workloads comes in,
it's wait on the pipeline
for the main threads
to finish the processing of the
workloads on the queue.
Which eventually what's happening
is that we have kind of
head of line blocking
that Elad showed you before.
Later Valkey introduced the IO threads
and the main idea behind the IO threads
was to offload all the IO
requests to the IO threads itself.
Simple idea, does the job,
double the performance,
almost close to 400K request per second.
And this time we are now more busy
on the process command.
50% of the time the
process itself was busy
on that stage.
Last year, specifically AWS and my team
contribute to Valkey,
the new IO threads architecture.
The idea is very simple.
We have the main thread that
orchestrate all the jobs
that span the IO threads.
Now we ensure that there
is no race condition
and the number of IO threads can be adjust
according to the workloads that running
on the hardware itself.
Now despite of the dynamic
nature of the IO threads,
the main thread also
responsible for the affinity.
And it also always make sure
that the data is assigned
to the specific thread.
So we can also enjoy from cache locality
and to improve the performance.
So with this ability we
can achieve even more
than 1 million requests per
second for single instance.
That was a huge win for Valkey.
So just to simulate that.
Now we have the main thread running
and every time that we
need to spawn an IO thread
when a workload is coming
in, we just spawn it out.
We can
process the workloads in parallel
and we can remove some of the IO threads
and to release some of
the compute once the data,
once the workload is relaxed.
Now let's see how everything
is playing altogether.
We talked about the warm pool,
we talked about the proxy itself,
we talked about the physical host
that we run in on a
multi-talent environment.
And here in my example I have a cache node
running with two calls, two IO threads.
Because we're running a very steady state
of 30K request per second,
this is the throughput.
But now let's assume that we
have some events that kicks in
and our customers expecting us to grow
and our instances very instantly.
So immediately we can scale
our throughput by eight time
because we assign more codes,
we are spawning more IO
threads to the cache node.
And in that way we can
scale up in parallel
in the midway, we are just
assigning more cache node
to the existing cluster
because we are using the warm pool.
The proxy automatically
going to detect that.
And all that happening in parallel
because encapsulated from
the, our application.
We started to move the
data from the old shard
to the new shard.
And in that way we can
scale the throughput,
double the cluster
capacity every two minutes
and achieve a very seamless
serverless experience.
Now I have a, I have here
a prerecord demo, nice demo
that we started with our
adding more workloads
to the cache serverless nodes.
As you can see I started
with 250K requests
per second and I'm going to
add more and more clients
and workloads to the,
my cache serverless nodes.
Now in the meanwhile,
while you see that the
throughput is growing,
my p50 latency is stayed
below the milliseconds
response time.
Which mean we are still
having the microseconds
response time even when
we pushing more workloads
to the cache node.
As you can see, I'm always
already achieved 100,
1 million,
more than 1 million requests per second.
And the p99 is going to
jump to three milliseconds.
And this is because we started
to move things, we are
using more IO threads,
we're using more hardware resources.
So it might impact the p99 latency,
but the p50 will stay behind
below the microseconds.
And the p99 will saturated while we finish
with all the scaling process.
So the demo will run until
we reach to 3 million
but we don't need to wait until that.
Now I want to recap and to talk about
few best practices that
we learned for today.
So we talked about connection pools,
persistent connection.
Every time that we
establish a new connection
is in order of magnitude
more expensive compared
to simple GET and SET
command of Valkey.
So using a connection pool,
using a persistent connection,
long-lived connection is very important.
We talked about reading
from replica to achieve
to scale the read throughput to achieve
high availability and resiliency.
And specifically for serverless,
it'll benefit you to
achieve the microseconds
read response time.
We talked about hotspot.
We have two mitigation for that,
specifically we talked about,
Elad mentioned about the key duplication
that you can duplicate the keys and read,
and use all the hardware resources
that you have on your cluster.
We talked about the key splitting
that you can split specific
key across your shards
and to read even more
throughput on that specific key.
And related to that we also,
as a key principle we say
limit your size of your object.
Because eventually if you have a large,
very large object, it'll
consume processing time and CPU.
And also the payload itself,
it can also reach you to a situation
that you're going to exceed
the network baseline.
Because we are talking about caching,
one of the most important principle,
how you can save your
memory, more freshness,
more close to the original
without a stale data and also specifically
with serverless it can also
help you to reduce the cost.
So time to leave expiry is the one
of the way to do that.
You explicitly assign them
to a key or set of keys
and you can use a relative
time or absolute time.
But one of the most important
if you're going to use it,
try to use the random
jitter when you delete them
because once they all going to be deleted,
we don't want them to be deleted
on the same period of time,
make your Valkey very busy with that,
we want to spread it across time window.
That was all today.
Hope you enjoyed the session.
Thank you very much.
Me and Elad will stay
around, you can talk with us
and ask question and
I hope you enjoy that.
Please fill the survey
and tell us how you enjoy for the session.
Thank you.
(attendees applaud)